[Music]
we begin with an aphorism by the
Viennese twentieth-century architect
Otto flows louis writes if we find a
mound six feet long and 3 feet wide in
the forests formed into a pyramid shaped
by a shovel we become serious and
something in a says someone lies buried
here that is architecture now there are
several things to attend to in that
little passage first of all it seems to
be a sort of unprepared encounter we
come upon a mound in the forest but
immediately we see that the mound has
been shaped someone has constructed it
and someone has constructed it into the
shape of a pyramid the mound is not
actually a pyramid the pyramid is
something that we have to construct in
the architectural imagination but
someone has given us markers they've
indexed the act of construction lo says
it's been shaped by a shovel so there
are tools involved with the construction
the tools indicate that there are
there's a craft involved there's
technique involved so we have an
encounter that involves the
architectural imagination constructing a
genre or a type which is the pyramid
it's a particular kind of construction
and we have craft or technique involved
but the shape of the mound and what we
call its indexicality that is its
marking the fact that it's constructed
and all these other features that Louis
recounts those are associated features
those are sort of part of the sensuous
experience they're really sort of
encrustations to the real object which
is a tomb or a pyramid or a grave of
some sort and then Louis says we become
serious this is important the the the
the first the consequence of the
encounter is first of all an
architectural effect we we become
serious the the the mound the shape of
the mound the appearance of the mound
has affected us so all these encrusted
features have an architectural effect
and only then
do we conceptualize only then do we
theorize someone lies buried here and
the summation of that encounter is the
conclusion that is architecture now what
is what is the VAT the that which is
architecture is not the actual
experience the sensual experience has an
effect but the VAT which is which is
architecture the real object of that is
withdrawn it's inaccessible we don't we
don't actually experience the that the
real object of architecture is
autonomous from my encounter with it the
sensuous object is part of the encounter
the sensuous qualities inhabit the
encounter we can understand this if I
close my eyes the sensual object
vaporizes evaporates but the real object
the that which is Architecture is still
there it has its own autonomy its own
identity separate from the encounter